you do have different accents every like
30 minutes I can tell you which area of
Liverpool someone's from so the Beatles
which is slower is South Liverpool also
just like London oh that's what they
sound like and I think it's a bunch of
[__] they've moved around they've been
all over the world but like there's some
private school kids bro just just talk
that [__] it is what it is they're [__]
billionaires you can't be a billionaire
with this voice
[Laughter]
so they sold out is that what you're
saying totally okay none of them ever
[__] came back Paul McCartney Come
Back quite a bit John Lennon couldn't
come back because he got shot in the
face yeah Ringo's like I'm never going
back how did Liverpool react when he got
shot in his head I wasn't alive
you were alive
bro you know everything in all of
Liverpool's history